اعتدى جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على مراسل
الجزيره منتصر نصار والمصور المرافق له في
منطقه وادي الشاج نه جنوب بلده دورا في
منطقه الخليل حيث هجم فريق الجزيره بينما
كان على سطح احد المنازل استعدادا للبث
وانهال جنود الاحتلال على الزميلين بالضرب
وصادروا المعدات ومن ضمنها الهاتف
النقال شو
بدنا يعطيكم العافيه احنا اللي صار كنا
نصور بموقع اطلاق النار طلعنا لايف بالوضع
الطبيعي دي واجا الجيش كمان مره كان جربنا
واحنا طالعين لايف خلصنا اللايف وطلعنا
ناخذ رشد وكان في عنا لايف بالنشره الجاي
فقررنا ناخذ لوكيشن افضل يعني فطلعنا على
سطوح منزل تفاجانا فجاه الجيش افتح
الاسطور ما حكاش معنا ولا حرف بس طرب يعني
اي
رب
الو صحين ين زعل فا كسرونا كسرونا ضرب اول
ما وصل كمان خبط القمره
وكسرها مسك الميكروفون وتبع
الاكسر ما اطنا مجال نحكي اصلا يعني اخذ
الكاميرا واخذ التي في واخذ
تليفوناتنا ورجع كمان فتشنا كمان مره وقبل
ما ينزل رد ردنا كمان مره
وصادر الكاميرا والتي في والمعدات كلها
تقريبا
وطلعوا طلعوا من
المكان ينضم الينا من داخل المستشفى في
الخليل مراس الجزيره منتصر نصار منتصر
بدايه الحمد لله على السلامه ما الذي جرى
معك نذكر بالذي جرى وكيف هو الحال الان
نعم فدا سلمكم الله جميعا الحقيقه الذي
جرى هو اننا كنا في بث مباشر ايه ل من
موقع العمليه التي حدثت في منطقه جنوب
الخليل وكنا قد انهينا هذا البث وكان جنود
الاحتلال متواجدين في محيط المكان الذي
اي تواجدنا فيه لم يامرنا جنود الاحتلال
بمغادره الموقع ولم يخبرونا بان وجودنا
هنا يشكل خطر عليهم او يعيق حتى عمل
القوات الاسرائيليه وبالتالي اي يعني فريق
الاخبار طلب منا الاستعداد لان نكون في
لايف جديد ننشره المقبله قررت انا والزميل
المصور ان ناخذ مكانا مرتفعا حتى نستطيع
ان ناخذ صوره افضل ل يعني اللايف القادم
وبالفعل يعني اعتلينا سطح احد المنازل وهو
بالمناسبه يعني موقع بعيد عن موقع الحدث
ولا يشكل اي اعاقه لقوات الاحتلال ولا
يشكل اي ضرر عليهم ما ان اعتلينا سطح هذا
المنزل وبدا الزميل المصور باخذ
الاستعدادات اللازمه للتجهيز للبث للنشره
القادمه تفاجانا باقتحام حوالي سبعه جنود
سطح المنزل الذي كنا نتواجد فيه لمجرد ما
ان تواجدوا عندنا اولا قاموا ب يعني ضرب
الكاميرا وكسرها وقام احد الجنود بالقاء
المايك الخاص بنا وكان موجود على هذا
المايك اللوجو الخاص بقناه الجزيره تم
القاء هذا الميكروفون من على سطح المنزل
الى اسفل هذا المنزل الامر الذي ادى الى
تحطيم اللوجو وتكسير الميكروفون ثم ان
علينا ضربا يعني رغم اننا نرتدي الخوذه
ونرتدي الدرع الصحفي ونحمل ميكروفون
الجزيره وكل المؤشرات ومعنا الكاميرا كل
المؤشرات والدلالات تقول اننا صحفيون نقوم
بعملنا ونحن بعيدون كل البعد عن الجنود
لكن ذلك لم يشفع لنا انهالوا علينا ضربا
انا والزميل المصور تعرضنا الحقيقه لعدد
من الردود والكدمات في سائر انحاء الجسد
نقلنا الى المستشفى وتجرى لنا الفحوصات
اللازمه والادويه اللازمه ايضا ونتمنى ان
شاء الله ان ن تماثل للشفاء قريبا
وبالتاكيد سنعود ونحن نتمنى لك ذلك وزميل
المصور شكرا لك منتصر نصار مراسل جزيره
كنت معنا من داخل المستشفى في
الخليل